welcome to the et mini carpet yeah I
mean this is way too tiny
no small red carpets you're still
special well speaking of stars you guys
this is your how many Comic Cons has
this been pretty bad come on I think
Bob's Burgers oh seven back your two
we're so grateful to all the fans and
everybody that watches and we're happy
that like the episodes are still really
good all the scripts are really a plus
and we've got some great stories coming
out this year do you feel like you're
set for life I mean how many more season
two you guys go not yet well I gotta
tell you have you guys seen any of the
crazy out there have you seen anybody
doing your character or some cosplay oh
no I can't wait that's my favorite part
see all the Linda's we're gonna do an
autograph signing in a little bit so
we'll get to see everybody so main
Tina's I read no it's not a couple
Tina's a big part of the show of course
are the musical numbers are we gonna get
a full soundtrack does anyone know you
guys know back there we gained a full
sound oh that's what you said last time
so soundtrack coming in September would
we ever get a full musical episode some
that come pretty close I would say
because there's a more room on the
carpet for everybody I want to know what
is your favorite burger of the day a Big
Lebowski fur I like we're here we're
queer get used to it a sharp cheddar
dressed man Cheeburger Cheeburger
Saturday Night Live from 1983 burger I
love standing cilantro
there's no cilantro on it because
cilantro is terrible that is like my
favorite that's just my favorite like
play on this family reps each other so
hard you guys like the Kardashians you
know I mean any comparison to the cadet
Kardashians is completely welcomed I
don't think you behind Khloe once and
she smelled really good yeah do a
Keeping Up with like the Kardashians
type episode soon worried about that get
a Kardashian on No